hello everybody welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll and i
do realize that by
reading my books listening to my
lectures even listening to the mindscape
podcast you can get an impression of
quantum mechanics and in modern physics
more generally that is a little way out
right we're talking about
uh parallel universes or quantum gravity
emergent space time evaporating black
holes it may seem a little bit removed
from the nitty-gritty of not just
experimental physics but also of your
everyday experience but of course
quantum mechanics itself was not
invented by theoretical physicists just
trying to think of cool things they were
forced to come up with these crazy ideas
by trying to explain the data by trying
to explain experiments and these
experiments have not stopped they've not
gone away and i'm not talking about
experiments that use quantum mechanics
those experiments have also been going
on a long time every particle physics
experiment like the large hadron
collider uses quantum mechanics to make
the predictions i'm talking about a new
generation of quantum mechanics
experiments that really digs into
entanglement quantum entanglement is
really one of the things that is special
about quantum mechanics makes it very
different from the classical world the
idea that different physical systems can
be related to each other in some deep
quantum way what can we do with that we
can build quantum computers we can do
other things as well so today's guest
monica schleyersmith is an experimental
physicist who works on cold atoms and
the reason why cold atoms are really
interesting is because when they're cold
you can entangle them and you can
control the amount of entanglement you
can shoot little photons at them and you
can sort of manipulate them in a very
very delicate way so ordinary atoms that
are hot or just bumping into each other
randomly they'll become entangled but
then unentangled and you don't know and
you can't really control it when you
really cool them down you have this
pinpoint precision control so you can do
a lot of different things you can do
sort of down to earth things which i
think was the original motivation
metrology uh measuring things to
exquisite precision but then guess what
the crazy theorists have come in and
ruined everything by pointing out you
can also
build models of quantum gravity and this
is one of the things that monica does
she in her lab at stanford builds uh
groups of atoms that are entangled with
each other in the right way that well
it's just beginning i wouldn't say that
we're there yet but it's
resembling uh
the features of a model of holographic
duality
the famous ads cft conjecture that juan
maldasena put forward you know almost 25
years ago now where you can have a
theory without gravity and a theory with
gravity and secretly they're the same
likewise monica can build collections of
entangled atoms that if you look at them
in exactly the right way resemble a
system with gravity and then you can use
what you know about gravity to make
predictions about what those atoms are
going to do it's still beginning stuff
very very cutting edge but the hope is
we'll both just learn more about quantum
mechanics and how to manipulate
entanglement and collections of atoms
but maybe also
learn a little bit about how gravity and
space-time do emerge from these
collections of atoms so the real lesson
here is that there's no real clear sharp
distinction between the down-to-earth
useful applications of quantum mechanics
and the pie in the sky theorizing that
me and my friends like to do so much so
let's go
[Music]
monica flyer smith welcome to the
mindscape podcast
thanks for having me so i want to start
with a slightly left field question
because
you're an experimental physicist i'm a
theoretical physicist uh in certain
circles there's a feeling
that theorists kind of glab grab all the
glory they hold all the credit you know
like experimentalists are in there doing
the hard work most physicists are
experimenters many more than theorists
uh but it's the theorists who end up
writing the books and being on tv and
things like that is this a feeling that
you either have or get
in your everyday work or or are you is
in your world it's it's happy
collaborations uh all around
yeah um that is actually not a feeling
i've gotten i do remember one of my
college professors saying everybody
comes into college thinking they want to
be a theoretical physicist
nobody thinks to do experiments and you
know there's something to the idea of
doing experiments um but no often um
you know i often tell my students one of
the things i love about being an
experimentalist is if i have an idea i
don't need to convince and it's an idea
that merits experimentation i don't need
to convince somebody else to do the
experiment um
it's on me to do it in my own lab um and
so i think that's you know and
technology is always advancing so that's
something that we can take advantage of
um so uh yeah i think it's wonderful
being an experimentalist and getting to
actually sort of um uh
kind of do things in the lab the data
sometimes just speak for themselves in a
way that you don't have to argue whose
idea it was um if you did the experiment
you did the experiment and did you start
off wanting to be an experimentalist or
did that come to you at some point
yeah that's a good question so um i
think
uh if i sort of think back to being a
you know freshman in college um
i was interested in um i actually loved
kind of abstract math courses where you
know i stayed up all night trying to
prove something right that kind of thing
so i certainly have had that theoretical
bent um and also enjoyed physics and
chemistry and i think that for me um
i wanted to go into a field of physics
once i realized it was physics i wanted
to do where i could maybe think about
some interesting ideas but not have my
whole job be to think okay yeah and so
what i love about my job is um there's
sort of the the hands-on part um these
days it's more the graduate students and
post-docs doing the hand on the last
yeah but there's sort of a varied aspect
to it we get to do a little bit of
theory on the side but the whole job
isn't to think and you're doing
experiments in the realm of quantum
mechanics which is great because you
know i've talked about quantum mechanics
on the podcast before most listeners
know that this is one of my things but
i would love to hear you know how you
explain quantum mechanics to the person
on the street uh
i i want to say as an experimentalist
but just explain it however you would
explain it i'm curious as to whether or
not we think about it differently
yeah so to me kind of the most um kind
of remarkable and revolutionary aspect
of quantum mechanics is the concept that
information
is not something that has to exist
locally so classically when you think
about information in your computer um
you know it's stored in individual bits
that are ones or zeros
um and in quantum mechanics first of all
we can have the concept of superposition
where a quantum bit is not just a zero
or one but it can be in um in a state
where until you measure it uh it's
somehow undecided what state it's in and
there's some randomness potentially in
the measurement outcome so that that
randomness is part of what's special
about quantum mechanics um i sometimes
like to use the analogy of a coin toss
so you know when we do that measurement
it's like tossing a coin that could land
heads or tails
um
but the cool thing about quantum
mechanics
um is also that there can be
correlations in the randomness so
i can be tossing a coin here and you can
toss a coin there and we could arrange a
situation where um every time i get
heads you also get heads and every time
i get tails you get tails and that would
never happen with an actual toy cost but
toy cost but that could happen with
measurements on a pair of qubits or
quantum bits um and that tells us that
kind of there's some information that
isn't
your information that's where are you
pasadena right now i'm in boston
actually so you're in boston okay
it's not in boston it's not in palo alto
right because everything i'm measuring
looks completely random but when we
actually um compare notes we realize
there's some information there so
there's this sort of information hidden
in correlations um and that that
phenomenon known as entanglement is
what's really special about quantum
mechanics and i i find that kind of
amazing that information can exist in
this delocalized fashion yeah i think
that this is exactly right so let me run
by you something that has been on my
mind because i actually am beginning to
write a textbook undergraduate level
textbook on quantum mechanics
i'm reading other people's textbooks and
i'm struck by how little they talk about
entanglement you know they just saw the
schrodinger equation over and over again
and the fact that there is entanglement
is mentioned but then it's breezed right
on by i mean uh
am i am i right that the modern frontier
of experimental quantum mechanics as
well as theoretical is very entanglement
centric
absolutely and you know you mentioned um
writing a textbook i i um haven't
written books but i teach a course for
freshmen on quantum mechanics oh wow um
quantum information and that's actually
part of what i have found amazing in
teaching this course is that you can
sort of start talking about entanglement
from day one um
and and certainly really start to get an
understanding of its implications in a
couple of weeks and actually at week
seven we get to the schrodinger equation
um
but we sort of flip it around and it
lets you get to some of the kind of
really cutting edge aspects of of what's
special about quantum mechanics yeah it
makes perfect sense to me um so yeah i'm
going to try to revolutionize the
teaching of undergrad quantum mechanics
by putting entanglement front and center
a lot quicker but um and but this i i
need to ask now do you have strong
feelings about the interpretation or
foundations of quantum mechanics
you know i think that that is it's like
it's a fascinating topic it's great for
sort of you know after dinner
conversations and
if you get a bunch of physicists around
the table everyone will have um heated
you know arguments um for me it's sort
of um you know at the end of the day
so far um you know there is a theory
that predicts very well everything we do
in the lab sometimes what we do in the
lab doesn't match the theory but then
it's usually yeah
that we didn't do what we thought we did
and we need to track down some source of
experimental error um and and so certain
aspects you know the um
things like
the heisenberg uncertainty principle
this idea that you can't know where
something is and how fast it's moving at
the same time um when you do experiments
that deal directly with quantum
uncertainty you really develop an
intuition for kind of where it comes
from and what are the mechanisms that
enforce that principle um and so i think
that there are lots of things that are
sort of mysterious about quantum
mechanics and one should stop and be
bothered about it and think about
interpretations
um
but it's not something i have um
strong feelings about there might be
some interpretations that i would take
issue with but yeah well next time we're
at the same conference so we'll have
dinner together we can talk about the
interpretations of quantum mechanics i
can give you a pitch for that
um uh but then
you mentioned the idea of measurement
right and of you know that
i guess the three big ideas that you
mentioned all of which i agree with that
come in when you start talking about
quantum mechanics uh superposition
measurement and entanglement right so is
there a simple explanation for why we
don't observe all this weird quantumness
in our everyday life you did the coin
flip example but then you were quick to
say not with real coins of course with
cupid's so why not if the real world is
quantum mechanical why don't we observe
all these things
yeah i mean i think a good example is
perhaps the the heisenberg uncertainty
principle that i mentioned um right so
there's a fundamental limit on how well
you can know where a thing is and how
fast it's moving its position and its
momentum
but for sort of
macroscopic objects that we encounter in
our everyday lives those uncertainties
are tiny compared to
um you know kind of what we can see with
our eye
compared to motion that has to do with
that object is at some finite
temperature
so usually in sort of our day-to-day
lives we're not observing things at the
scale where you would see these quantum
phenomena um and again
when you do experiments you often really
deal firsthand
or even try to plan experiments you deal
firsthand with sort of why it is hard to
scale up these phenomena um like quantum
superposition
i guess yeah and that's really what i
what i was going to try to get at
because
you gave a very sensible answer about
the using the uncertainty principle to
why you know quantum uncertainties are
there for individual particles etc but
for an experimentalist like yourself
isn't much of your job trying to make
quantum systems bigger and still be
quantum yeah yeah and so you know one
thing that i have for example thought
about a fair amount and i haven't
done an experiment like this but there's
there's various groups doing experiments
along these lines um is how would you
make
what you might call a schrodinger cat
state yes so a quantum superposition of
a cat being alive and dead
and okay so we like to sort of simplify
that down a little bit as physicists so
rather than the superposition of a cat
being alive or dead you could ask the
question can i make a superposition of a
group of atoms either all being in their
ground states or all being in their
excited states and fundamentally it's
unknown um which of those scenarios is
is is the one we're in until we do a
measurement right right um
that actually turns out to be a state
that is is potentially very useful if
you can make it it's a resource for
improving precision measurements of time
um so you know why is that hard to do
you need to um somehow
first of all manipulate this you know
collection of many atoms um
uh
actually let me give an example so you
could imagine maybe you can do this by
having
um i sometimes like to think of the
ground state and the excited state as um
a spin that points down or a spin that
points up good um or equivalently maybe
a spin that points left and a spin that
points right but two opposite
orientations i mean probably for a lot
of people the spin pointing up or down
is is makes more sense intuitively to
them than an excited stated non-excited
state yeah exactly and so you can
imagine maybe trying to do an experiment
where um
you i send some light that interacts
with a group of atoms um maybe i send
send a photon if the photon
is in one polarization state it will
rotate the spins one way if it's in a
different polarization state it'll
rotate the spins another way for example
um and so um uh and then if i uh but in
that type of a system i could create
something that's this superposition of
the spins oriented in one direction or
the other and maybe i can just scale
this up and do this with more and more
spins or more and more atoms and make
more and more macroscopic superposition
states um
and then you sort of run into the
problem that um
uh
the larger i try to make my system the
higher the probability that one atom
does something it shouldn't do
or you don't want it to do it
it decays from an excited state to the
ground state there and there's a photon
that leaves and hits and in principle
could be observed by somebody um and
that would give that observer
information about the state of that one
atom and that would so the speak
collapse the entire superposition state
so basically the bigger you make the
system the harder it is
to control what you don't know about it
right about it and it's this idea of
sort of superposition it's all about
having this
this kind of quantum system where
there's something unknown about it until
you perform the measurement so there's
that risk that you accidentally um let
some information leak to the environment
that destroys that delicate
superposition state
and so that's something that when you
plan an experiment you can sort of
immediately see why it gets hard but but
you just said that you uh have
contemplated this but you haven't
actually done this particular experiment
trying to put as many entangled
particles no no in part because in part
because it's hard it's hard
but there are you know sort of the state
of the art there are a couple of
physical systems where people have done
things like this for what's around 20 um
spins right so that's kind of the state
of the art so you can go beyond just a
single um spin
or cubit in a superposition of zero and
one um you could scale it up to about 20
and i'm sure this will keep getting
pushed um uh and
well this is what we we need to push for
quantum computers right when you say 20
qubits i mean that's a 20 cubit quantum
computer is is we we haven't had
anything more than that i guess is what
you're saying
um
yeah so i mean i guess you you know if
you read the news you know they're
50-ish cubit quantum computers um
depending you know what you define as a
quantum computer but um yeah um
yeah so and what exactly is the kind of
system that you're working with i mean
you gave us some some kind of conceptual
things but what what happens in your lab
when you're pushing these bottom systems
around yeah great so so what do we do in
my lab so first of all um
the general system i work with are
systems of laser-cooled atoms um and so
um perhaps it's a little
counter-intuitive we can use lasers to
bring atoms to
temperatures that are sort of in our lab
millionths of a degree above absolute
zero i mean maybe it's worth explaining
a little bit about that when i think of
shooting a laser at something it sounds
like i'm going to heat it up but you're
somehow cooling it down
yeah yeah exactly um so so there's a
trick we use um which basically relies
on the doppler effect
so you know i wish i could wave my arms
and the listeners of the podcast
they can imagine the basic picture you
can have in mind
is we have
some atoms flying around you know
they're initially at room temperature
and we have um
uh laser beams basically that are um
counter propagating so if we want to
slow the atom down in a particular
direction we would have two laser beams
that are pointing in opposite directions
and um instead of tuning those laser
beams so that they can resonantly be
absorbed by the atoms we tune them so
that they're like a little bit too low
in energy or too low in frequency to be
on on resonance with the atoms um but
there's a this phenomenon of the doppler
effect it's the same thing where you
know if i'm sort of driving along the
highway and a truck comes the other
other way you know the faster it's
moving the more it's kind of frequency
will be shifted upward um
sound higher pitched in the same way to
the atom depending which way it's moving
the sort of laser beam will seem like
it's higher pitched or at a higher
frequency and this results in a
phenomenon where the atom is more likely
to absorb a laser beam that's
propagating in a way that will kick it
to slow it down then a laser beam that's
propagating in the in the other
direction um and so so that basically
means you get this preferential
absorption of photons that slow down the
atom give them the momentum kick that
slows down the atom
and then the photon it's slowed down and
now it emits a photon
um
and actually that emitted photon then
has a higher energy than the one that
was absorbed
because uh the atom is now uh
uh
if if it's sitting still it'll uh yeah
if it's gone from sort of moving to
sitting still the energy of the mitts
will be different so that gives you a
way to extract energy um uh from the
atoms and um sort of put it into the
light field and also the atom emits some
photon in a random direction
so actually the entropy of the light
field goes up okay some sort of disorder
that's getting um uh pumped into the
light field and the atoms can be more
ordered than and ultimately sitting
still
after hours of dedicated research
nothing feels better than the
satisfaction of finally finding the
information you've been looking for
you get that same incredible feeling
when you're able to find the next great
hire after a candidate search with
indeed if you're hiring you need indeed
indeed is a hiring partner that gets you
what you really want a short list of
quality candidates as fast as possible
because you can do it all attract
interview and hire at indeed you don't
have to struggle on your own to find
quality candidates indeed can help you
hire the right people right now because
indeed partners with you on every step
of the hiring process you can find
talent with the skills you need through
tools like indeed instant match
assessments and virtual interviews
and there's no need to install anything
extra indeed virtual interviews work
from your browser so get started right
now with a 75 sponsored job credit to
upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape indeed.com mindscape offer
valid through december 31st terms and
conditions apply need to hire you need
indeed
so just to make sure i get this i'm a
perfect podcast host for this because i
actually don't know anything you're
talking about i mean i've heard
colloquial on it before but i'm not an
expert so i'm learning here in real time
so the great thing about the procedure
you just outlined is that it's not like
you're trying to be maxwell's demon and
observing the velocity of all the the
atoms you're you're flooding them with
light with the property that they will
if they're moving too fast in some
direction they will absorb a bit of
light and slow down and then they'll
kick then they'll kick out another
photon and you're left with a very bunch
of cold atoms
that's right yeah okay and what kind of
atoms are we talking about what element
um so in my labs we work with either
rubidium or cesium
those are both in the first column of
the periodic table so they have one
valence electron which gives you sort of
a relatively simple atomic structure um
to electronic structure to work with um
they have sort of convenient laser
frequencies that we can use to address
them um yeah so and how many atoms are
in a little group that you're working
with at any one time
yeah so um typically this this starting
point of of of laser cooling um gives
some cloud that could have um you know
could easily have 10 million atoms in it
let's say um but we don't um and then
that's sort of just our the first stage
of our experiments um
and then um you know i have a couple of
different labs that do different things
but for in in actually um one of the
things we've been doing is um doing
experiments where we have little clouds
of atoms that are individually trapped
and asking how much control can we get
over the ways that these atoms can
actually interact with each other right
um and sort of the the general
motivation is we talked earlier about
entanglement in order to generate
entanglement one needs sort of some way
for the atoms to interact um now
ultimately the sort of conceptually
simplest thing one might want to do and
there are some um labs that do this is
have sort of an individual atom um
trapped at the focus of a laser beam and
have perhaps some array of those
individual atoms so that um you can kind
of
control think of each one as a qubit
right and and and form some kind of a
quantum register so they have every
single atom pinned at one location yeah
exactly um in things that i'm currently
doing in my lab we work with little
clouds of atoms each one pinned in a
focused laser beam um and that for for
what we're doing right now happens to
have some advantages so that but that's
kind of what you can you can picture is
sort of um a bunch of little clouds of
atoms um sitting in uh kind of a a a
line um trapped one next to the other
and then how many atoms are we left with
or how many effective cubes and so we so
each little cloud has um a few thousand
atoms um and um we can have let's say 20
of these little clouds um yeah
all right and that so are the individual
clouds
does it even make sense to ask this
question are they like
solid or
gas yeah yeah yeah i think they're very
gas okay um
you know so so the atoms within the
individual clouds um that you know they
can move move around um freely they're
to lowest order not really interacting
with each other they're far apart
compared to the size of the atom so
they're sort of
at micron scale distances apart right
whereas the the size of the atom is on
on the angstrom scale and are they like
sitting in a bowl or something what
prevents them from just falling to the
floor
yeah and so that's that's where lasers
come in again so so much of what we do
involves using lasers so the first step
i said was cooling them but also then we
hold them in place we essentially kind
of are levitating them um or yeah
essentially trapping them
by using the fact that
the atom
can basically
experience an attractive force
when it's or a force that attracts it to
the intensity maximum of the laser beam
okay um
so this is you can kind of think of it
as you have this oscillating electric
field of the light
which can polarize the atom
um and so that allows the atom to
um so so the light sort of induces some
polarization in the atom that's along
the field direction so it can lower its
energy um by being in the presence of
that oscillating field which is the
light maybe one somewhat down-to-earth
question here is what does the lab look
like i think that most people like have
an image of the large hadron collider as
a physics lab and i think that it's a
different scale that you're working on
here
yeah that's a great question so um the
typical scale first of all in terms of
sort of the number of people um who are
um operating such a you know a machine
where we laser cool and trap the atoms
and do our physics it's typically um you
know three or a team of three or four
people working together
very different and you know and they're
in a room that's something like uh you
know 500 square feet
um to give us kind of a sense of scale
um
and so
they will have you can picture basically
having several optical tables so imagine
a table that's um
something like
five feet by nine feet or so
that has on it um
well so in a typical lab we might have
one table that has a vacuum chamber
where our experiments happen so we need
the atoms these atoms these particular
atoms we care about let's say the
rubidium atoms to be isolated in ultra
high vacuum i want them to bump into air
molecules or whatever right yeah
um
and um so there's that vacuum chamber
all the pumps needed to create the
vacuum um and then uh
various uh lots and lots of kind of
optical components so laser beams that
are used to do the cooling and the
trapping and manipulating the atoms
which
we usually prepare
this laser light on another table um
send it into optical fibers that carry
it to where the experiments happen so
you kind of you can adjust something at
the laser end without needing to
readjust everything um at the vacuum
chamber side okay um and so there's yeah
so there's sort of a couple of these
tables with lasers on one the vacuum
system on the other
lots of electronic components um often
kind of home built to do do what we need
to do so every laser needs to be at
exactly the right frequency and we're
constantly measuring and feeding back to
make sure it stays at the right
frequency so lots of um feedback loops
um and things like that so a lot it
sounds like a lot of the day-to-day work
of one of your graduate students is
tending the lasers
well and that actually depends a lot on
kind of the stage we're at in our
research so i would say
in sort of the early stages you know
there's kind of really a custom built
apparatus that the graduate students
they need to design and build and set up
the lasers and get them all the light
into the optical fibers and at the right
frequencies and then eventually you know
the graduate students aren't you know
pressing buttons to turn on and off the
light that that that is all automated
right so they're
writing computer code that tells all of
the lasers for example what they need to
do in the magnetic fields and so forth
and so then the day-to-day life comes
becomes more um about writing that
script that's telling the
apparatus what to do analyzing the data
which is you know some images let's say
from a camera that tell us what we what
the atoms are doing um and yeah and so
that there's sort of a shift then to
kind of sitting at a computer and making
sure um and telling the experiment what
to do analyzing data and every so often
perhaps going and fixing something on
the experiment table
and the ultimate goal is we want to
entangle these things so what is it that
is entangled is it is it individual
atoms within a cloud that you're
entangling with each other are you
entangling different clouds
yeah so one of the things we're
currently very interested in is how one
can have some kind of like
programmability of what this the sort of
graph is of entanglement that we can
create um and um i will say that in my
lab we're actually currently working on
you know can we actually quantify and
prove that there's entanglement in our
system and that takes um a fairly
sophisticated set of measurements um uh
that are in progress um but what we've
done so far is show that we have a high
degree of control over basically the
structure of interactions and those
interactions are the mechanism for
generating entanglement um and so what
what we are most interested in well yeah
and so both of these things are
interesting generating entanglement
within a cloud generating entanglement
between the clouds what you would care
about depends a little bit on
what application you have in mind um and
for us there are a few different
directions that we're intrigued by which
range from sort of preparing states that
could have applications in precision
measurement or in computation
um
or
simulating phenomena from other areas of
physics and you know one that i'm
intrigued by is connections to gravity
that you actually probably know more
much more about than we're gonna get
there believe me i'm just yeah
so depending which of those things you
want to do you might want to entangle
things in different ways yeah no i'm
just luxuriating in all the you know
vicarious uh pleasures of being in the
lab without actually doing any of the
work um so how does the entanglement
come about do the atoms bump into each
other or interact with each other or do
you does like some separate manipulation
get them into an entangled state
yeah so um
one way generically one way to entangle
atoms is actually to let them bump into
each other um
and that is something that uh
is not the the focus in our lab and the
reason that we're kind of interested in
actually going beyond that and being
able to
let atoms interact that aren't directly
bumping into each other is related to
this idea i mentioned right at the
outset that the special thing about
quantum mechanics is that information
doesn't have to be local that it can be
stored in these kind of non-local
correlations and if you want to kind of
efficiently build up non-local
correlations then it would be great to
be able to have kind of interactions
that don't rely on things being right
next to each other right um
and so one of the things that we do in
our lab is actually use um
again use light um so use photons to
carry information between atoms that are
far apart so you know the atoms again
are kind of angstrom scale objects but
we can have a photon convey information
from one atom to another atom that's a
millimeter away or from one little cloud
to another cloud that's a millimeter
away
and so for us that's that's a very long
distance exactly yeah on the scale of
our experiments um and and so that's uh
yes that's one of the key approaches
that we use in our lab and
you already alluded to this but uh can i
get more details on this question of how
do you know that things are entangled is
it just you trust the rules of quantum
mechanics because my impression is that
entanglement itself is not measurable at
least in a single measurement maybe you
could sort of do it over and over again
yeah and so in the experiment you always
need to basically prepare the same state
many times um and do a set of
measurements um that so that allows you
to do kind of complementary measurements
that give you um kind of more yeah more
than one piece of information about the
same state even though the measurement
does uh fundamentally change the state
right so that's why we need to redo the
same experiment and measure a different
quantity um one of the ways that we're
actually um
currently working on is um
using
some insight from kind of the field of
precision measurement
um so so
there are known fundamental limits
having to do with the heisenberg
uncertainty principle that i mentioned
before or if i have a collection of
atoms that are unentangled
what is the best measurement that i can
do in our case we're not looking at
position or momentum but you could ask
for example what is the best measurement
i can do of the strength of a magnetic
field okay um that makes these you know
these spins that i think of these atoms
as spins and that makes these spins
rotate
um
and
again you know this
phenomenon of quantum superposition
means that when we measure the state of
an atom it's kind of like a coin toss
there's some randomness um and we know
if we were to you know flip 100 coins on
average 50 would land heads and 50 would
land tails but there'd be some
fluctuations around that and that just
comes from the statistics of a binomial
distribution so um uh
and so those fluctuations scale roughly
with the number of the square root of
the number of coins you tossed or in our
case the square root of the number of
atoms that we did our measurement on um
so
that sets a limit to how precisely you
could you know measure a magnetic field
using the atoms and if we can do better
than that limit
then actually that is one way of in a
very sort of operatively useful way um
saying there's there's entanglement in
the system so that's the type of
measurement that we're um uh currently
kind of working on it requires making
sure all the technical noise is is not a
limitation and that you're really just
seeing the quantum noise um uh yeah and
so far so so far we've seen kind of
evidence that we have the right
structure of interactions to give rise
to entanglement and we're working on
showing you know is it really
entanglement and like you said that
requires sort of performing measurements
of um
uh
the sort of the spin in different
directions so if there's a full set of
measurements one needs to do so just to
be clear to the people who are not
quantum mechanics experts here if i have
an atom a single one that may or may not
be entangled with other atoms there is
literally no measurement i could make on
just that one atom that would tell me
whether it wasn't tangled is that right
can you sorry can you repeat the
question if i have if i focus in on one
atom yeah that may or may not be
entangled with others and i think about
measuring just that one atom there's
nothing i can measure that would tell me
whether there was entanglement with it
elsewhere
that's exactly right yes yeah okay yeah
so you have to be clever this is what
was what you might see something like
that again if we had that state we
described before on the so-called bell
state where it's you know a
superposition of
both coins being heads and both coins
being tails if we just look at one of
them everything looks random right and
we can't tell and that's that's
generally true that i need to somehow
look at both
um parts of the system
when you give the charity how much
impact will your donation actually have
this question can be hard if not
impossible to know
most charities can't tell you how your
money will be used or how much good it
will accomplish you may know will
theoretically help a cause but how and
more importantly how much
if you want to help people living in
poverty with evidence-based high-impact
charities i recommend you check out
givewell
givewell spends over 20 thousand hours
each year researching charitable
organizations and only recommends a few
of the highest impact evidence-based
charities they've found over 50 000
donors have used givewell to donate more
than 750 million dollars
rigorous evidence suggests that these
donations will save tens of thousands of
lives
and improve the lives of millions more
if you've never donated to givewell's
recommended charities before you can
have your donation matched up to 250
before the end of the year or as long as
matching funds last to claim your match
go to givewell.org and pick podcast and
enter mindscape at checkout make sure
they know that you heard about givewell
from mindscape to get your donation
matched
and i got the impression from looking at
your website etc that one of the
things that you are specializing in is
the fact that um
you know it's relatively easy to get two
atoms to be entangled if they're right
next to each other but you you are b
you're trying to be separating the sort
of physical proximity of different atoms
from their entanglement so you can have
different kinds of entanglement
structures i guess maybe explain what i
mean when i just said that uh what does
it mean to have different kinds of
entanglement structures can anatomy
entangle with many other things or is it
just one at a time
oh yeah that that's a great question i
mean first of all there is sort of a
rule called monogamy of entanglement
which says you know if i can have two
things that are kind of maximally
entangled um or i can have many things
that are all sort of weakly entangled um
so so there are some trade-offs there um
one thing that um
and and yeah as you said we'd like kind
of control over the structures of
entanglement one thing i've worked on on
the past is having sort of the opposite
limit of two things which are strongly
entangled which is having many that are
sort of collectively um entangled um so
if i have a cloud of atoms and every
atom can talk to every other atom um
that gives a way of making a certain
type of kind of collective entangled
state that does have applications
actually in enhanced precision
measurements um and that is actually
something i worked on in my in my phd
thesis was using that type of kind of
collective entanglement
to make states that are useful for
enhancing the precision of atomic blocks
so that's kind of one simple limit is
like everybody is is is talking to each
other and there's a collective form of
entanglement all to all another limit is
sort of maybe pairwise entanglement that
you could get by having some nearest
neighbor interaction
um
and what we would love to do is kind of
be able to explore between those two and
really control kind of the the the
structure of interactions and explore a
wider range of quantum states and did
you ever expect when you started doing
this kind of thing that you would be
modeling quantum gravity
um no
yeah
but it happened apparently that is what
is going on i mean uh i'm not sure what
the best way to approach this is uh do
we have to talk about ads eft
um
perhaps yeah i mean i could say a little
bit about how i got interested why don't
we do that in this topic i think maybe
that yeah so um
you know again so my background had been
in this area of kind of you know quantum
metrology um um i was building a lab
where i have ways of letting atoms talk
to each other with light that's a little
bit you know different from letting
atoms collide with each other um and
somewhere along some time when we were
kind of working on getting the lab set
up um i had
um a conversation with a theorist named
brian swingle who at the time was a
postdoc at stanford
um
and
he you know has a background in i guess
everything from condensed matter physics
to quantum gravity
and you know so very complementary to
mine um but was interested in whether
one can do experiments that would probe
um a phenomenon known as information
scrambling um which is sort of trying to
get out what happens to information that
falls into a black hole
so sorry just to again be clear there um
is the phenomenon of information
scrambling unique to black holes or is
it a property that systems have
including black holes and maybe
maybe explain what it is
right yeah yeah so so um to the best of
my understanding this sort of term was
maybe first used in the context of
thinking about black holes and asking um
uh about you know is information lost
that falls into a black hole and i our
understanding is no it's not lost but it
is very quickly scrambled which is to
say it kind of um gets uh hidden in
complex quantum correlations and
entanglement and it's something
information that was initially locally
encoded in one quantum bit would become
quickly very delocalized um uh and
there's a conjecture known as the fast
scrambling conjecture that there's sort
of a fundamental limit to how fast this
can happen um and that that would happen
in um essentially black holes
or perhaps we should say systems that
are and now you mentioned this id
concept ads cft
um in systems that are
do that are
dual to black holes under the framework
of what's known as holographic duality
so um
i almost feel like i should let you
explain this
more of an expert let me say a couple
words about it and then you can fill in
for what is relevant to what you think
about it so uh yeah we did have neda
engelhardt on the podcast uh a few
months ago and she's an expert so the
idea that there one walda cena back in
the 90s explained that there is a
certain set of theories
uh quantum field theories without
gravity so things we think we understand
pretty well uh in n dimensions where n
is some number like four
uh and then there's also theories with
gravity super string theories in
particular but maybe it's broader than
that uh
that have a certain background geometry
anti-dissider space right so like a
cosmology with a negative vacuum energy
and there's a relationship between these
non-gravitational theories and n
dimensions and these gravitational
theories and n plus one dimensions and
the relationship is supposed to be
they're the same theory and it's not
completely clear to me that it's true
that they're the same theory but they're
certainly very very similar in
in relevant operational ways so the idea
is that we can learn about a real theory
of quantum gravity in the context of
this dual theory without gravity where
presumably we understand things better
how they do right
yeah and and so to to me what was
intriguing about this idea or one there
are actually a number of things that are
intriguing about it but one was this
idea that
in certain cases you could have on one
side of the duality a strongly
interacting quantum system
um whose properties might seem like they
should be hard to calculate um and on
the other side there's kind of
a way to actually visualize aspects of
this you know in highly entangled
quantum system in terms of curved space
and gravity that it might give us some
kind of way new ways of being able to
think about strongly interacting quantum
systems to have some ways of visualizing
um what generically you might worry is
something that requires kind of an
exponentially large description um so
that there's so so that was one thing
that to me was kind of intriguing about
hearing about this so the the relevance
to what you do is that you can imagine
setting something up that resembles in
some way
the
non-gravitational side of the duality
but then if if dualities like this are
real
in some other way looking at it you're
doing an experiment that involves
gravity
exactly yeah or that mimics gravity
simulates gravity i mean you're not
actually putting something heavy in your
lab and feeling its gravitational force
right and that's also you know a
fascinating direction of research can
one do precision measurements in a
regime where quantum mechanics and
gravity both matter but that's not what
we're doing that's right um so um we're
kind of asking can we build
um quantum systems in the lab where
there is this idea of some kind of
emergent extra dimension um uh that you
know has has curvature that might be
that maybe we can think about as a
gravitational system is that um you know
something that might apply to systems we
can actually build and then
um you know i think that connects to
broader questions you know there are big
there are big questions about does
gravity in our universe is that actually
something that emerges fundamentally
from quantum mechanics i don't feel
equipped to answer that question
um but we can explore the concept and
maybe it will help us actually think
about um have new ways of understanding
quantum systems um and
entanglement you know that when uh
pencils and wilson discovered the cosmic
microwave background their their famous
paper just said we measured some excess
antenna temperature i'm not going to say
what it is right
right yeah
that's what other people worry about
they won the nobel prize anyway it still
counts um so in other words let's see um
the the the hope is that there are
certain kinds of theories there's kinds
of physical situations you can set up
where
they have the properties that if all
this fancy theorizing is correct there's
a dual description that seems
gravitational
right
and presumably these setups of entangled
sets of qubits or atoms or whatever are
not are not just lying around you have
to work hard to create them
right
yes and that is what you're trying to do
is that is that fair
yeah so i think um
we are
so
let's see um so we're trying to create
as a starting point one thing we've done
is kind of build um what i would say is
kind of a toy model for this idea of
kind of an emergent geometry that
describes something about the structure
of the correlations in the quantum
system um
and
for me sort of that um
starting from some and this is something
where you know based on things we wrote
on paper we had an idea of what we
should expect to see in the experiment
but nevertheless um seeing that feels
like this a starting point for thinking
about how you can connect to these um
these theoretical ideas and then the
hope i think ultimately is that one
might build a system where one doesn't
know
um sort of that there is this this
picture some picture in terms of an
emergent geometry but one discovers it
perhaps by measurements and it tells you
something about the system right so that
might be the longer term goal um
uh
yeah so
so let me let me actually just dig into
that a little bit um
the with what you've done so far i guess
the question is are we are you learning
things from the experiments right now or
are you just checking that you're
getting the answers you expected by
doing the experiments so far i would say
that we are um first of all kind of
developing a level of control right
in the experiments to be able to
so so just as an example i mentioned um
sort of first hearing about some of
these ideas of holographic duality in
the context of the phenomenon of fast
scrambling and one of the things that
struck me there was that the
models that people write down on paper
um that are supposed to behave in this
way of exhibiting fast scrambling have
rather exotic-looking interactions that
are not local right right um and that
was one of the things that first made me
think well maybe actually you know we do
know how to realize not precisely those
models but systems with non-local
interactions um uh you know um is that
something where um we might be able to
explore that phenomenon or build other
toy models that would be sort of hard to
realize in in other systems where you
have you know nearest neighbor
interactions on the lattice so good i
mean let's let's take sorry let's dig
even closer there because i think that
probably a lot of people think of
entanglement as an interaction but it's
not right
you have something different in mind
when you say uh i mean how do you make a
long-distance interaction in your world
right and so in our in our experiments
um what we
so essentially i mean
interactions actually are always local
but we can make things that look
effectively like non-local interactions
by letting photons carry information
very quickly at the speed of light you
know from from one atom to another
and so
effectively at the end of the day what
we have is what looks like the atoms
interacting we actually can kind of
ignore the photons at the end of the day
and say it looks like these atoms
interacted even though they're a
millimeter apart
that's our mechanism for generating what
i would call sort of effectively
non-local interactions and again just
for the people out there who uh listen
to this in similar podcasts this has
nothing to do
with the spooky action at a distance
that einstein worried about right
because that's when you measure a spin
and now you know the the
if it's entangled you know the state of
some other spin on alpha centauri or
whatever but you're actually just
creating entanglement or manipulating
entanglement between spins you're not
collapsing the wave function by doing
some measurement on them
exactly so the first step is to ha is to
generate these interactions which can
create entanglement and then ultimately
to see whether you have entanglement you
do need to perform that measurement um
and you would perform a set of
measurements that do look like they're
showing what einstein called spooky
action at a distance of course we
understand um how it comes about um and
and one key thing is that information um
did need to sort of travel from point a
to point b to generate that entanglement
and so i mean maybe you said this but it
got lost i mean have you made quantum
systems that exhibit this fast
scrambling that they hypothesize for
black holes
um no not yet okay so um and so one of
the things we had started to think about
is sort of with the toolbox that we're
building um
what are some models that might exhibit
this fast scrambling um and we had you
know i had a toy model that i'd been
thinking about for a while where instead
of having let's say nearest neighbor
interactions on a lattice you have
interactions at
um a distance of one site two sites four
sites eight sites any power of two
and that was actually somewhat different
from um you know models that are known
to be holographically dual to black
holes um but it has this feature that
actually in a sort of um
information can spread exponentially
fast kind of from one point to any other
point in the system so the
characteristic time scale for the local
interactions for information to spread
from one site across the entire system
would scale linearly with the system
size here it can scale as the logarithm
of the system size so that you know i
had kind of this toy model and was um
had an idea of how we could actually do
that in the lab and then somewhere
actually in the context of kind of
thinking about this toy model
um
my actually my graduate student at the
time um greg benson started kind of
asking theorists whether there's like a
more rigorous way to think about this
model than my kind of hand waving
um i can count how yeah
my hand waving sort of arguments um
and
uh
and and through a rather serendipitous
chain of events um greg came into
contact with steve guptzer
at princeton who um
rather remarkably um it turned out that
this toy model we've been thinking about
um if you tweak it a little bit
connects to a version
of this ads cft correspondence of
holographic duality um that that steve
formulated
that is actually really kind of builds
on some some very deep ideas and number
theory i can go deeper into that um if
it's of interest um um but that actually
then led us to this idea of
by tweaking that toy model we actually
could build something in the lab that
has some sense of an emergent geometry
um
that looks a little bit like
anti-descender space okay so let's just
sketch our breath here um so uh
if we didn't know any better if we were
just dumb and naive and had a bunch of
atoms on a lattice and we poked at one
of those atoms uh with a bit of
information or something like that we're
being very hand-wavy here uh what you'd
expect is the information would then
spread out to the nearest neighbors of
that atom and then their nearest
neighbors and they're so it's spread out
linearly over time but what you want is
or what you what the conjecture is
happens in gravity and black holes is
faster than that so you poke one atom
and it spreads out all over the place
and you're able to build toy models of
that
that's right yeah and and so we haven't
really directly probed the scrambling i
would say what we've done so far is show
that we can build this graph of
interactions right okay yeah and then so
and then presumably where groups or etc
come in is that
it's one thing to make these non-local
interactions it's another thing to make
them of precisely the right form to
look like gravity in some dual theory
right
that is yeah that's certainly true
that's another thing to make them of the
precise form to look like gravity in
some dual theory um
and i mean so far kind of the toy model
we've realized in the lab has um there's
it has some parameter we can tune and
there's a particular point where it does
have this feature of um
to the best of our understanding
actually you can't quite really do the
theory for a scalable number of
particles but to the best of our
understanding it could exhibit fast
scrambling at some point but that i'm
not claiming that it's the holographic
duel of a black hole and then there's a
different place you can tune it to where
it has some features that bear a
resemblance um to uh uh a system where
there is
a kind of an emergent geometry okay um
that looks like a curved space but it's
not actually a fast scrambler in that
regime so okay
that's fine um so what is the
where do we make our money doing this
are we are we saying that i mean at the
end of the day you have a bunch of atoms
and you don't really have gravity in in
some sense are we trying to learn things
about
systems that have some dual
gravitational description or is there is
there a question that we don't know
about those systems that you're going to
answer experimentally
i think what i would like to understand
better and again to to be honest i would
say
lately we've been focused on building up
a toolbox yeah sure of course and
and for a while i actually sort of
stopped chatting with theorists because
i thought
you could always have billions of ideas
but if you can't do the experiment then
where does that get you um no but but
now i i think to me one question is um
if
let's say we have this particular toy
model where it does seem that there is a
sense of what we might call a
holographic
bulk geometry um
and is is there some predictive power to
that so and and i don't have a sharp
answer to this but is there a sense
where having this geometrical picture um
helps us predict something about the
dynamics of the quantum system i see
okay helps us understand you know what's
the most efficient way to um transfer
information from point a to point b in
this collection of qubits for example um
is and i i think that there are things
there where actually the gravity this
this um it's not precisely gravity but
this picture of this bulk geometry
actually should give a useful way of
thinking about the behavior of the
quantum system and i feel that having a
toy model in the lab to play with that
and hopefully soon more than one model
right um
is kind of a starting point um so i
guess i feel that there's always there's
value in doing experiments it's sort of
well yeah uh
for me at least clarifies things to
really think how do you do this in the
lab um just to give maybe also one
example so
um what you know i think is fascinating
theoretically is the idea that there is
a direct connection between we talked
about entanglement earlier between a
property called entanglement entropy
which is a measure of entanglement in
the quantum system
and
the geometry in this extra dimension
um so there's this idea that the amount
of entanglement entropy in some region
on the quantum system that lives on the
boundary of this higher dimensional
space is connected to the area of of
sort of a particular surface in in the
in the higher dimensional space in the
bulk um so that is something where that
would be kind of cool to see in a system
where you can directly you know measure
that in the lab and there are some
experiments where one can measure
entanglement entropy but also you can
ask does do you need to measure that or
at least as an experimentalist you
naturally say well are there simpler
experimental observables that will kind
of you know get at some of the same um
physics and in our experiment so far
entanglement entropy isn't something we
can measure um and we were actually kind
of surprised even though when we'd been
doing some theory before we had made
some plots of you know what the
entanglement entropy would do in a
system like this
and we were sort of surprised that
actually by being forced to work with
what we could um there were simpler
observables that kind of actually showed
some of the same physics right um and so
that type of thing you don't really have
to think about until you're confronted
with it in the lab but perhaps you can
learn something from that yeah no i mean
i'm entirely on board that experiments
are just simply worth doing right
yeah can't just have theorists talking
to each other all the time but but just
so i think i finally get some logic uh
from your explanation that i hadn't
gotten before so let me play it back to
you and you can tell me if i'm on the
right track so you have the system of
atoms with entanglement and you know
you're poking at them with photons and
whatever and in principle
i could imagine taking a giant computer
and solving for what the system is going
to do using the schrodinger equation but
in practice that's just impractical
there's too many degrees of freedom too
many things going around
but if the specific arrangements of
entanglement and
um have this holographic dual that is to
say there's a way of thinking about them
that looks like gravity in an extra
dimension
it's not gravity in extra dimension you
know there's we know how many dimensions
there are et cetera but you can use that
knowledge to make a prediction for
what's actually going to happen in your
experiment and then you can test to see
whether that comes true
yes yeah yeah and i think that sort of
the sort of fundamental challenge that
we never really explicitly stated in our
discussion about entanglement earlier is
the fact that having a you know a full
description of a quantum system that i
could let's say put on my classical
computer that description grows
exponentially yeah with the number of
particles you know and even for you know
50 some particles that just won't fit on
the world's largest super computer right
that's right
and and so that's where the question is
sort of
under what circumstances
is there a simpler description
and in some cases and you know there's
lots of work on that by people who
are pushing the state of the art in kind
of numerical simulations of quantum
systems
um and in some cases where it's a
one-dimensional system and you know you
have nearest neighbor interactions it's
kind of known how to more efficiently
represent the classes of quantum states
that you would naturally get from that
and in certain cases but um in more
generic cases um uh
it's not obvious necessarily and the
hope is that um
their this holographic duality could
perhaps give um an approach that lends
itself to some um some quantum systems
where currently we don't know how to
efficiently right um describe them
and is it is it too much to ask that we
might learn something about quantum
gravity by doing this like are you going
to address questions about black hole
information loss
so
i don't think that i personally can
solve those
problems because a lot of other people
have thought about them much more deeply
than i have so you know so what can can
we contribute um i think we can talk to
the people who've thought more deeply
right um and
and
so
and and we can kind of again build these
model systems and see how they behave in
regimes where you might not be able to
calculate it yeah um right and that's
and i would say actually right now we're
still working in the regime where we can
calculate what happens well in our
system that has something to do with the
fact that we work with little clouds of
atoms that you can think of a bit more
semi-classically um and so there's still
i mentioned a lot of this is about just
developing the experimental tools so
there's a path to getting to systems
that are more in a regime where it's
let's say one cubit per site and it has
a simple theoretical description on
paper but nevertheless it's hard to
calculate um what will happen right um
and uh
so
in that regime um
the hope is that sort of by with you
know the right sort of dialogue
um between
us and other experimentalists who can
build systems in the lab and theorists
who might know exactly what is the right
question to ask right to learn something
about um information in black holes that
i think that that dialogue is essential
yeah and part of it so for example but
you know you mentioned before
if one can build a system that's a fast
scrambler that's not a sufficient
condition for having the holographic
dual of a black hole
but it is a necessary condition and then
you can start at least to the best of my
understanding um and and so then you can
start to ask you know give
you can explore can we build things that
maybe it's not actually easy to
calculate um
uh what will happen but you can measure
it in the lab and people are thinking
about more and more refined tests for
whether the system is or it might or
might not have a gravity tool beyond
just asking how fast is information
scrambled
and so i think there's a lot of kind of
parallel work in terms of
making experiments more capable and
thinking about what are the right
measurements to perform
i don't know if this is a fair question
but you know in the original work by
moldasena the
non-gravitational
side of the duality was this very
specific theory right
super yang mills theory with a lot of
super symmetry et cetera et cetera so
should we be
so
how confident are we that just from a
bunch of rubidium atoms you can mimic a
system like that are we are we confident
that we have the right properties
um
no
certainly not but i to me one of the
questions is like how
um generic
are these ideas yeah about holographic
duality and i believe that theorists are
often restricted to you know thinking
about models that they have the right
tools to analyze
right um it would be great if the
concepts generalize beyond those models
yes okay right
and what we can do on the experimental
side
is
build systems that we might have some
reason to believe are interesting like
oh i think this seems like it should be
a fast scrambler maybe it's interesting
right um
and
uh and then learn something in regimes
where you can't um easily analyze it on
paper yeah now i'm a big believer in
doing the experiments and being
surprised and then realized oh i should
have thought of that all along right
yeah yeah
and i guess uh it's worth before we
before we end i do want to come back to
the fact that there are other reasons to
do these experiments other than
pretending to make black holes
or whatever so
i mean you know what those reasons are
better than i do but one that you
mentioned is precision timing
measurements so how does that work
yeah so um
generally speaking you know one of the
reasons that um
we love atoms is that atoms are our best
measurements of time um and you know the
set the second is defined in terms of an
oscillation frequency in the cesium atom
um
and uh one place uh where and and
actually sort of the best clocks made of
these laser-cooled atoms um really are
at the point where um one of the
limitations on their performance is
quantum uncertainty that sort of coin
toss noise that comes from the
randomness of these acts of projecting
an atom into one of two states
um so this is one place
where um entanglement can help you kind
of
introduce correlations that if one coin
lands heads another is more likely to
entail so to speak and so the
fluctuations and that total count are
reduced i see um and so that's um a
direction where entanglement um
certainly can can help and there's
lots of work going on in terms of just
um taking
some things that have already been kind
of demonstrated and applying them
towards the world's best clocks um
one of the questions i'm kind of
fundamentally interested in is um
the sort of simplest states one could
make um uh and that have been made are
so-called squeezed states that have that
sort of collective entanglement every
atom is entangled with every other in
sort of an equal way and those are
certainly it's well understood kind of
why those are useful for those
applications but one of the questions
i'm kind of interested in is if you can
have um richer structures of
entanglement does that also have a
benefit for sensing and in what
cases does it have a benefit and that
might be
that you're trying to get more
information than just measuring one
single quantity like um it might be that
you're trying to actually um
image a magnetic field or something um
you're trying to right you're trying to
uh uh or get information that's uh how
is some signal varying as a function of
time what are the spatial correlations
in the signal so kind of there's not
that much there's i would say we're at
an early stage of understanding kind of
how
richer structures of entanglement can
offer benefits um in
uh both sensing and timekeeping tasks
and so that's something where um the
more we kind of build up this toolbox
the more we can start to even explore at
a fundamental level um um how to harness
um
entanglement um how to fully harness it
as a resource for precision measurement
i'm sure there's very good answers to
this question but why do we want to have
even more precise measurements of time
than we already have like we're pretty
good at it now yeah yeah
um
well you know one of the um you know we
talked earlier about sort of different
ways of of probing gravity actually
right
or harnessing holographic duality um but
perhaps actually um can you really do
measurements in the regime where quantum
mechanics and gravity are both playing a
role
and the best atomic clocks
are um just extraordinarily um
precise and to the point where if you
have just a very small change in the
height of the clock
i think by now probably on the
millimeter scale um one can actually
you know that changes the rate at which
the clock ticks because of gravitational
redshift um and so you can actually um
really sort of resolve that and see
these these um effects of general
relativity in um the atomic clock right
and in this case you're talking about
real honest to goodness gravity making
apples fall from trees not uh you know
dual gravity in your theory yeah yeah
and and so that's so i would actually
say one of the sort of um motivations
for better clocks is that actually you
can do better and better precision tests
of fundamental physics their ideas for
using clocks to detect gravitational
waves and regimes where
sort of different parameter regimes from
ligo and things like that so um that's
that's kind of one direction and it
seems
maybe this is too naive on my part but
it seems from all the words you use that
maybe quantum computing is an
application for this kind of thing or do
you learn anything that is then relevant
to quantum computing
yeah i mean so so one of the things that
um we're interested in so certainly
generally entanglement is kind of the
fundamental resource for quantum
computing so you know in a very general
say sense anything that advances you
know what types of entangled states you
can prepare might have some computing
application but at a more sort of direct
level you know
there's sort of the goal of building
a universal error-corrected quantum
computer and then there's a kind of goal
of asking are there certain classes of
computational problems that might
naturally map to um sort of existing or
near-term hardware in the lab um uh and
can we can we sort of ask whether you
know the quantum systems that are
natural for us to build can solve
certain classes of problems and so in
that vein
there's a whole
class of optimization problems okay that
can be mapped to essentially minimizing
the energy of an interacting spin system
um and generically those problems so
these are things in the fl in the vein
of traveling salesman problem that can
be you know certain scheduling problems
and things like that um generically
those require some spins with non-local
interactions
um
and
um it turns out that you know so so if
you can and to have a particular problem
that you're solving you need to be able
to basically program the graph of those
interactions um and you'd like to also
control you know the sign of the
interaction do the spins want to align
or anti-align and how strongly do they
want to do that so sorry when you say
the graph of the interactions we have
some atoms that we know their locations
and then the graph of the interactions
is given atom a and some other atom b
how strong is this interaction
exactly yeah and also what is the sign
of it do they want to realize
or whatever yeah okay
yeah yeah
um
and so
so having these programmable non-local
interactions
um
is a great way to start exploring
does this quantum system
um
give you a way of efficiently solving um
these certain classes of problems that
are known to be hard classically and
it's not there are lots of you know
there's lots of theoretical work on you
know can quantum systems help with this
or not and there are certain cases where
um you know it's known that that they
they won't help or certain approaches
won't help and certain cases where it
looks like the quantum systems can help
and then a huge wide open space where um
i really think you need to kind of play
with the systems and um uh and and learn
right from experiments um and so we
naturally now have a way of making these
non-local interaction graphs we see some
evidence that we have a way of kind of
naturally generating what look like low
temperature states of this interacting
spin model
um and we would love to go deeper into
exploring for sort of you know the cases
the types of graphs that are hard
classically um can our system find the
ground state and so forth so and and
it seems to me as a quasi outsider that
the field is a is advancing pretty darn
rapidly i mean how
how do you see what's the
what this field is like 20 years from
now in terms of how many spins are being
entangled and what kind of systems
you're looking at
yeah um you know 20 years i think it is
really hard to predict because like you
said even just in the past few years
there have been quite rapid advances um
i i would say um
you know one area where there's been
in this field of cold atoms
substantial progress in the past few
years is the ability to really scalably
create arrays of individually trapped
atoms
where one can have you know an ordered
array of hundreds of atoms that you can
look at one by one and sue pretty soon
hopefully manipulate any one of them um
individually um there are ways of having
kind of nearest neighbor interactions um
that are um explored in um a number of
labs and it's actually also something we
work on in a different setup than the
one i was describing i'm having kind of
so you can either have local
interactions or one thing that so far
from that toolbox is kind of missing is
having this longer range connectivity
that could be really valuable in this
context of efficiently um
implementing certain quantum algorithms
or generating certain structures of
entanglement um and so to me like for
this is maybe not an answer for the
field as the whole but one as a whole
but one thing i'm kind of excited about
is can we kind of merge these um
different technologies of the ability to
have um uh sort of more control over the
graph of interactions with this really
scalable single particle control
and this is the kind of thing where you
could do it much much better if you had
a billion dollars or is it is it just
you need time in the individual 500
square foot labs and eventually we'll
get to the point where you need a lot
more money i would say you i would say
um for things i'm working on i would say
we need time in individual 500 square
foot labs there and sort of the
ingenuity of you know grad students and
post docs coming up with kind of yeah
clever solutions and um uh uh
and that's partly sort of i think my
taste is doing some some things that are
a little bit um
uh you don't already know how to do it
right if i knew how to do it and that
just money would solve it you do
something else we'd be less excited
than i am about things where i have a
sense that there's something interesting
to explore but i don't really quite know
what the answer is yet yeah i think
that's a the perfect place to end and
you've convinced us all that we need to
understand entanglement better
theoretically and experimentally so
monica schleider smith thanks very much
for being on the mindset podcast thanks
so much again for the invitation
[Music]
you